[Music]
at a rehearsal for the trooping of the
color on horse guards parade in London
the heat was too much for some Medical
Teams rushing to help as soldiers
wearing bare skin hats struggled to cope
with temperatures as they climbed
towards 30 degrees
Prince William inspecting the Welsh
guards on Horseback tweeted his thanks
for those who had endured the difficult
conditions
heat can be especially dangerous for the
vulnerable and at this Elderly Care home
in weybridge they paid close attention
to the health warnings for our residents
we can keep an eye on them we can
obviously we can we offer drinks we've
got Hydration Stations everywhere ice
lollies ice creams
iced melon as well anything that they
want to be able to get get them through
this hot period and obviously just
making sure that we're keeping up a
dialogue with our residents and making
sure that uh that they know that they've
actually been in the Sun for a little
bit they might want to try Shady spot
Etc even the homes
popular garden
as little respite
I love the heat I love sitting out in
the sun but at the moment it's getting a
bit too much
so I sort of drink a lot
and I sit out in the sun for maybe half
an hour then I go in the Jade
and what do you do to yourself cool
other than going in the shade drinking
and not gin and Tony just drinking water
or lemonade
of course it's not unusual for it to be
hot in the summer but these temperatures
are above average for this time of year
and climate scientists are telling us
that heat waves like this are made more
likely and more intense because of
global warming that means potentially
adapting to many more impacts beyond the
medical we're going to see a lot more
forest fires wildfires it's quite
daunting really isn't it and a lot more
thunderstorms there's gonna be a lot
more drought I think farming is going to
get harder honestly and soil health is
going to struggle so it's going to be
something we're really going to have to
adjust to many with the means to cool
themselves down are enjoying the kind of
weather you might normally expect in
Spain but it hasn't been this hot this
early in the summer in England for
nearly 20 years a sign perhaps of the
more severe conditions that the UK must
prepare itself for
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News